a look at what's coming up on c-span
this is book notes c-span 60-minute
discussion with the authors of public
policy historical and political works
for the next hour you'll see behind the
titles and gain insight into the authors
as people and the experiences which
shape their lives
this week our guest is civil war
historian harold holtzer he joins us to
discuss the recent book the lincoln
douglas debates
[Music]
harold holtzer
editor
of
the book put out in 1993 the lincoln
douglas debates why do you think
something like this would sell this year
well it was a year when we were focused
on presidential debates or right after
the presidential debates
um
and
i thought and publisher obviously
thought that there would be some
interesting comparisons to make between
the styles of
the debates in the c-span larry king era
and in the lincoln douglas debate era
what's the thing when you go out and
speak to people about this that they
what are the greatest misconceptions
about the lincoln-douglas debates oh
there are many uh one is that they were
full of uh high-minded philosophical
lofty sentiments that's one which of
course is not true uh just quite the
opposite in fact the other that uh that
lincoln cornered douglas uh so that he
could elevate himself into the
presidency and doom douglas's chances
for the presidency two years down the
road which is another misconception but
it's mostly this idea perpetuated by the
way during this year's debate season by
admiral stockdale
in his vice presidential debate he uh
got his biggest applause line when he
mentioned that he had just finished
reading the lincoln douglas debates and
he realized that douglas
i think he said was full of little
stinky numbers
and lincoln was filled with the high
moral ground or took the high moral
ground
he must have been reading it backwards
because it isn't quite the way the real
lincoln douglas debates reads
let's go through all the details
who was douglas
stephen a douglas was the two-term
new england-born
illinois bred
senator from
illinois
seeking a third term
he
was
a powerful democrat in the united states
senate a leader of the senate a leader
of efforts to hold off civil war through
a series of compromises
and he was the father of a doctrine
called popular sovereignty
wherein
people in a new territory would have the
right before that territory became a
state to decide for themselves whether
to allow slavery in that new territory
where was he from
he was well he was
originally he was from vermont i think
and he uh but grew up in illinois as a
young man came to illinois dropped the s
uh off his name so that he had one ass
instead of two otherwise he would have
been perpetually confused with the
person who he didn't like very much
frederick douglass who in fact he
brought up during the mention during the
debates in a derogatory fashion
because he saw frederick douglass at one
of the debates
riding in a carriage seated next to
white women
and he used that horrifying spectacle as
a warning to the people of illinois this
is what illinois will become if you
elect abraham lincoln to the senate
black people and white people will quote
co-mingle which of course was was
supposedly supposed to send chills of
horror down the spines of people from
illinois
so he was a racist in addition to
everything else not unusual in 1858
and a great public speaker
known for
ripping his clothes off one one garment
at a time as he spoke in the heat of
debate
first his coat and his vest
then his tie
people worried that
they would joke that if douglas had
given speeches longer than two hours he
would have wound up on the senate floor
with nothing on but his undergarments
at the risk of somebody saying i can't
believe you asked that question who was
abraham lincoln
aside from being the physical opposite
of stephen a douglas
who he certainly was douglas was called
the little giant and lincoln at that
point was known
by the nickname long abe he was a
one-term congressman he had served in
the 1840s in the congress as a whig
and he was a
co-founder of the new republican party
a leader of the illinois republicans and
a well-known attorney successful
attorney but mostly known as a party
leader or public speaker on behalf of
other candidates he had tried for the
senate a few years earlier
in a campaign that was
not really a campaign it was just
decided in the legislature with no
pre-campaign no debates
and he had nearly made it but his party
forsook him during the balloting and
elected a different fellow so he was
making his
second real effort for the senate
and this time he said he would only do
it if he was nominated for the senate in
advance which was not the practice in
those days so the republicans met in
convention
and they
they uh
nominated lincoln as their first and
only choice for the united states senate
and lincoln responded with his famous
house divided speech that was his
acceptance speech
and
their upon a campaign began which was
unusual because senators were not
elected directly by the people in 1858
they were elected by the legislatures so
sort of a parliamentary style election
we'll come back to uh more of this the
house divided species in particular but
where was abraham lincoln from
born in kentucky
lived briefly in indiana and then
spent
his adult years his his formative adult
years first in near charleston illinois
which became one of the debate towns
interestingly and then moved to new
salem illinois
a small river mill town where he
supposedly according to folklore got his
first schooling in letters
met the first woman who interested and
inspired him and rutledge
and uh determined to become a lawyer and
a politician
in that log cabin community this is a
little bit out of sequence but at some
point a couple points you talk about the
the romance
between stephen douglas and
the woman that married abraham lincoln
mary right i'm not sure if i would call
it a romance but i would
that's been exaggerated by films and
novels they certainly knew each other
douglas spent a good deal of his early
years in springfield before he moved to
chicago and uh he was supposedly quite
interested in this young
lexington kentucky belle mary todd who
was shipped from lexington to
springfield to live with her sister so
that she could catch a a husband and he
was a pretty attractive candidate
for marriage a successful booming voice
a leading politician but she uh she cast
her eyes on this unlikely fellow
who supposedly said to her i'd like to
dance with you in the worst way
prompting her to say that was exactly
the way he danced
and she later
she later said she said very little
about it but she did write that douglas
and others were part of her coterie in
springfield but
my idolized husband was above them all
how did you get to all this what do you
do for a living normally
well after eight years working for
governor mario cuomo
and in fact doing a lincoln book with
him which was a terrific experience for
me and i think for him as well
i now am the chief communications
officer for the metropolitan museum of
art
and when did you start on this book
um
let's see which employer am i going to
offend by admitting but i in in 92
right after we finished lincoln on
democracy with the governor
it occurred to me that
the book we did with the governor was a
collection of speeches and letters of
lincoln
on the subjects of democracy and
self-government self-determination
the governor had
had agreed to do it at the request of
the solidarity teachers of poland who
had no material on democracy
they worried for the moment when the
iron curtain fell in eastern europe so
they asked him if he could recommend
something he recommended lincoln who's
always been an idol an idol of his
and they replied that the communists had
removed lincoln from the bookshelves in
1945.
so he said i've got a guy working for me
who can do a book we'll do it together
we'll produce it we'll have it
translated into polish and that's what
we did it took a year and a half
but poland has several thousand copies
of this book uh in schools and libraries
in warsaw it's called lincoln oh
democracy in polish
and we produced it in the united states
as well
anyway enough of a plug for that but in
the course of doing that
it occurred to me that a lot of the
materials we were working with
when
when they were representing lincoln
speaking
extemporaneously were not up to the
standards that we've come to expect from
the gettysburg address and the second
inaugural address which are written so
magnificently
i wondered how it was possible
that a politician who had such
difficulty speaking
oh at railroad stations and at hotel
windows when crowds called for speeches
things we included in lincoln on
democracy because he occasionally said
crucial things at these junctures but
how
that man who had such difficulty
speaking extemporaneously
could have spoken so
seamlessly
uh and eloquently throughout the course
of the lincoln douglas debates
hours and hours of uh speechifying and
rebuttals and rejoinders with with
always the perfectly parsed sentences
and moments of ringing uh eloquence and
i thought
there was something there that we hadn't
found yet and that was what led me to do
this
new look at the lincoln douglas debates
how old was stephen a douglas how old
was abraham lincoln
lincoln was 49. douglas was younger
that's a good question about 45.
this is the first
complete unexpected text what does that
mean
well
um beyond the uh the hype it means
that the previous versions of the
lincoln douglas debates and there have
been about 40 of them
and they were all but canonized exactly
this way in the collective works of
abraham lincoln published about 40 years
ago all of them relied on
texts that were
down at the time by
what i call partisan stenographers
stenographers hired by the respective
political parties the republicans
uh hired stenographers to work for the
republican newspapers the democrats
hired stenographers to work for the
democratic newspapers
it was lincoln
who decided
after these debates were published
in the newspapers to have them published
in book form uh he then
used the approved text of his speeches
the approved text of douglas's speeches
did some more editing himself and
produced the version of the debates that
we know
to this day
the problem with that is that
they differ markedly from the opposition
transcripts the democratic transcribers
also took down what lincoln said and the
republican transcribers also took down
what douglas said the purpose was about
two or three days after each debate
the full text texts of the debate
appeared in the newspapers and of course
there was no recording equipment at the
time and no other way to get the text
except to have the shorthand reporters
take down the debates
but what had never been looked at was
the democratic version of what lincoln
said the republican version of what
douglas said i suspected that they would
be
a lot rougher than the material that
we've
come to accept as the authentic text
texts of the debate and in fact they
were lincoln had a great deal of trouble
parsing sentences as i suspected he
would he was nowhere near as eloquent uh
in in the soaring moments of the debate
as he was in the in the transcripts that
his fellows his supporters had worked on
and he himself had edited so i thought
this would give us bring us a little bit
closer to that
unique political culture that made the
debates possible these this rollicking
atmosphere of uh celebration and
spectacle
that uh occurred in each of these debate
towns during those months of campaigning
i'm gonna hold this up so that the
audience can see it but in the front you
you have a rundown uh of where these
debates were we need to get a little
closer so the audience can see exactly
where they were
the date was 1858
and you see there two in august two in
september and three in october
where were those towns
well ottawa and freeport were in the
northern part of the state
jonesborough
was
way in the south in fact it was called
the the
the part of the state in which the
debate took place was called egypt that
was the nickname no one knew whether
that meant that it was hot and sultry
down there or whether it was because
the uh the most famous town there was
cairo but
douglas kept saying during those first
two debates i want to trot him down to
egypt and bring him to his milk whatever
that means it was considered a very
untoward thing for a senator to say
charleston was in the middle of the
state
and again that's
was where lincoln's stepmother still
lived she lived not far from there
galesburg was back a bit north and it
was a college town knox college and the
debate took place on the grounds of this
rather progressive college very much for
lincoln and with quincy and alton we
moved back down south and west toward
the river
so it was really it was the the towns
were
all over the state
chosen by stephen a douglas by the way
he selected the venues why
well because he was in a position to
make uh demands um
it the the process began in an
interesting way
douglas was much better financed than
lincoln and much better known even in
illinois
and lincoln was having trouble getting
attention for his uh
mason campaign so he devised this idea
that he would follow douglas around to
wherever douglas was
campaigning and after douglas gave a
speech lincoln would give a speech in
the same place
and thus he said i'd have the last word
on him
so in chicago douglas spoke in the
afternoon lincoln spoke in the evening
and in springfield their hometown uh and
the state capitol uh
lincoln douglas spoke one day and and
lincoln followed him the next day
well the democratic press started to
make fun of lincoln they said that it
was as if he was a circus performer
picking up with the menagerie and moving
from town to town
and the republican paper the chicago
press and tribune now called the chicago
tribune
proposed this idea of joint debates
lincoln picked it up picked up the case
immediately and challenged douglas to
debates
and um
douglas knew from the beginning that
this
process could be of no benefit to him he
was coasting at that point he had a
stacked legislature there that was
almost certainly going to re-elect him
to the senate to begin with the last
thing he needed was to waste his time
facing lincoln face to face of course as
close to face to face as they could get
one fellow being five foot two and the
other being six foot four
but all the code of honor of the west
dictated that you couldn't very well
refuse so douglas had to accept the
debate challenge
but he drew the line
uh when lincoln said let's meet 100
times all over the state
douglas said no lincoln said how about
50 times
douglas said forget it
so douglas said we'll meet
in the county seats
of each of the counties and we'll leave
out cook county because you already
followed me in chicago
and we'll leave out sangamon county
because you followed me in springfield
so that leaves seven counties and we'll
meet in seven county seats and take it
or leave it so lincoln took it
how long were the debates
each debate was
three hours
incredibly enough
and the format was nothing like the
debates we have today
the first speaker
the opening speaker spoke for 60 minutes
without stop
and then the rebuttal speaker
spoke for one and a half hours
90 minutes again uninterruptedly and
finally the first speaker had 30 minutes
to
answer the rebuttal
three hours altogether each time
and audiences
not only endured it in both the
blazing heat in august in
in freeport for example and ottawa but
in the freezing rains that suddenly
whipped up in the uh in the fall
they they loved it it was spectacle it
was theater it was religion it was the
fourth of july it was it was the big
these were the biggest events to hit the
prairie in in these people's lifetimes
and they knew it were was there
amplification equipment no there was no
amplification equipment
um which makes one wonder about these
some contemporary descriptions of
lincoln's voice as uh
shrill and unpleasant
clearly these
politicians of the 19th century were
equipped with
incredibly strong voices it had to have
been a prereq a prerequisite for a
political career because there were
twenty thousand people
in freeport
um fifteen thousand ten thousand at some
of the other debate towns the smallest
crowd was the fifteen hundred in uh down
south in egypt in jonesboro but these
were huge crowds and they were milling
around there were no seats except for
vips and for ladies
and there was such a crush for the lady
seats that in one of the debate times
the entire bench collapsed sending all
the ladies down this slanted
slanted half bench down to the floor
at one point there's a reference that
there were no ladies present
um at some of the debates there were no
latest presence but at others they were
they were there and
given the only seats
that were available except for the
conestoga wagons and the covered wagons
that some of the people arrived on
people sat on their wagons it makes you
it makes one wonder how many people
actually heard the speeches and how many
people were out for the
for the celebration
um
you know you had ice cream being
consumed in picnic barbecues
um
liquid refreshment a lot of liquid
refreshment uh fights breaking out in
the back of the auditorium the back of
the crowds uh a cannon being fired off
douglas traveled with his own cannon
that was the only amplification around
he traveled with a brass cannon and his
supporters were instructed to fire it
every time he got off a good point
against lincoln so there was lots of
noise
lots of crowd
yelling and cheering and booing and
talking back nothing like the debates
today
where we our candidates make such an
intentional and careful effort to
to take the high ground and to be very
calm and not answer negatives and
fighting and audience attacks were part
of the game
1858 you know how many people there were
in the united states and how many people
there were in illinois
i don't know either but obviously i
think
15 million in the united states 20
million something like that 3 million
slaves
but i don't know the illinois population
what was illinois as a state slave
non-slave
illinois was changing immigration
was changing the face of illinois
slaveholders were slowly moving out
disappearing into the south as illinois
was abolishing slavery on its own ground
it was a state really of two halves the
northern half was much like the north uh
in the rest of the united states
committed to stopping the expansion of
slavery at a minimum
um
abolishing it some people believed a few
people not many people were for
abolition but the southern part of the
state
bounded by southern states and the
mississippi was very much pro-slavery
and
one county in illinois
a county where lincoln had spent part of
his youth
voted once to bar blacks all together
from entering the county i think by a
substantial majority so it was uh
still very much a racist state believing
in the supremacy of the white race but
edging toward a liberalization because
of new population shifts
how big a deal were these debates back
then around the country
they became news after a while
to understand why again requires an
understanding of the these uh the
newspapers of the day uh they were not
nonpartisan like today's newspapers
purport to be um
they were either republican newspapers
or democratic newspapers and the
republican papers around the country
decided that this fellow lincoln was
making
some interesting noise out in the west
not the midwest in those days but the
west
and they began republishing the texts of
the debates and also sending
correspondents out there to take the
measure of this political ferment that
they were hearing about so there were
eastern correspondents on hand and the
democratic papers were publishing
douglas's
debates because they saw in douglas's
likely re-election a vindication of
popular sovereignty and this notion that
slavery could expand in fact through
popular vote
if you had to pick one of the seven
debates
to go to and watch which one would you
pick
over here and i guess i'm asking is was
there one that stood out over all of
them all the rest well
i would choose the second debate the
freeport debate probably just for
personal reasons because lincoln
probably was at his best at freeport he
um up at the top of the state top of the
state parallel with chicago not too far
from chicago right it's the same same
latitude exactly but he had not done
terribly well in the first debate
which is
introduces us to why he did so much
better at freeport at ottawa i mean this
was a new a new ball game for him he was
a bit outclassed
and um
douglas posed some
rather direct and challenging
interrogatories to lincoln and lincoln
chose not to answer them in his
rebuttal it was probably a tactical
error he he had
probably chosen what he wanted to talk
about and he was intent on talking about
about that
um
and
douglas
slaughtered him in the in the uh
rejoinder really took him to task for
avoiding the issues
and um
after the debate lincoln was carried off
by his supporters in quote triumph
unquote um
some some of the democratic press teased
that they should have carried him off
before the debate started but it was
even the supporters saw it as sort of a
comical thing because
um as they carried him off his pants
rose higher and higher until his
underwear was exposed he must have been
wearing long underwear even in august so
his underwear was exposed to the knees
and to see his legs dangling practically
to the floor must have been pretty
comical sight
and his supporters were not happy when
they read the transcript and they said
one of the chicago republicans
sent said for god's sake tell him to
charge chester charge
um people wrote to him saying you've got
to wake up you've got to uh
you've got to fight back
so comes freeport
and lincoln gets right back at douglas
and answers all of those interrogatories
and poses the famous freeport question
which has divided historians ever since
about what lincoln's intention was it
says to douglas
let me ask you something you talk about
popular sovereignty
what if people in a territory
before forming a new state constitution
vote not to have slavery even down in
the south would you accept that and he
said well i would have to that's popular
sovereignty
many historians have concluded that that
was lincoln's way of destroying douglas
in the south and ensuring that he could
never win a presidential election
two years down the road i had my
questions about that but it was an
awfully clever
thing to make douglas admit to
when was the first time you ever read
the lincoln douglas debates
um
i'm not sure i read them through at one
sitting ever until i was ready to do
this book um
a historian named reinhard lutheran said
that the lincoln douglas debates are
vastly more admired than they are read
and i think i'm living testimony that i
read them all at one point or another
but
they're not easy reading i mean
in the days before broadcast
reports of the news
candidates had to repeat themselves at
every at every stop
they couldn't be sure that their words
had been properly understood
in the hustings in towns that they
hadn't made personal appearances in
by the way lincoln made 60 speeches
during the campaign the debates were
just a fraction of his effort and
douglas made 130 speeches
they really worked those small towns
harper collins published this book uh
have they made their money yet
yeah i think they have actually
and if they haven't i wouldn't tell but
i think they have judging from the last
statement i think we're doing very well
when um when was this book is
copyrighted in 1993 when it actually did
it hit the bookstores i think it hit um
at the end of the fall right after the
presidential campaign between the
campaign and lincoln's birthday which is
always a good time to bring out lincoln
books is there any way to profile the
kind of person that went in and bought
this book
well fortunately for me because i write
about lincoln so often um
and i have a couple of other projects
that are going to be coming out later in
this in this year um the profile is uh
mostly people who are very interested in
the middle period of american history
there are a great many people who have a
fascination for lincoln and will
happily buy just about everything that
comes out as long as they get to know
about it which is always the key
and
but i think that there was
an audience out there who was interested
in the political process beyond the
lincoln douglas aspect
one of my happiest surprises after the
book came out was
seeing a profile of james carville in
the new york times sitting in front at
his desk with a row of books behind him
and i saw the lincoln douglas debates
there
can you remember in the campaign how
often you saw reference to lincoln
douglas debates
often but i see it in every campaign and
and politicians are always guilty of the
same thing canonizing the lincoln
douglas debates and calling it some and
referring to it as some lost ideal of
american political discourse a clinton
did it stockdale obviously did it
governor cuomo did it when he ran for
mayor of new york in uh in 1977 i i was
his press secretary then i remember that
very well but you know these
there were occasions in the debates when
lincoln threatened to stop up douglas's
mouth with a corn cob
um
douglas used the word [ __ ] constantly
to taunt lincoln and republicans did
lincoln use the same word he did on one
or two occasions uh-huh
he did
interestingly he did it in a northern
venue
and when he got to jonesboro the
southern town he was on
very good behavior and was actually said
i i know you people don't agree with me
but let me explain my position on race
and on slavery and he was actually uh
quite high-minded at that debate but
yeah he did use the word
where did you grow up
in uh in new york city
in the city in the city of manhattan in
queens same borough as mario cuomo which
was my uh my saving grace with him where
did you go to school queen's college the
city university when did you first get
interested in history or abe lincoln
lincoln was a a school assignment in
sixth grade i never remember fifth or
sixth because it was the same teacher
but it was a school we all had to write
biographies of
of
a famous people and we literally drew
them out of a hat not a top hat but a
hat and i drew lincoln and my friend
dennis drew genghis khan so i
for want of
that opportunity i might not have found
lincoln
that's the most frequently asked
question of people who write about
lincoln and i have just about the worst
answer in the uh in the lincoln
fraternity
how far do you go with this
uh lincoln s stuff i mean do you have
pictures on your wall and books in your
shelf and i mean are you a real link in
the file yeah not so much pictures on
the wall but certainly i have a library
that permits me to
do my research at home after work and on
weekends so that i don't have to travel
to uh to libraries i just finished a
project on letters from the american
people to abraham lincoln during his
presidency but that required a lot of
microfilm work because obviously the
letters are here in washington so that
was microfilm what kind of a person
would he be if he were sitting here do
you think
that's the second most off frequently
asked question oh how would he do today
in politics well it's very hard to
transpose the
the
the lincoln who could afford to wear
you know ill-fitting clothes and
travel on coach
during these debates and
generally looked like he had just you
know slept for 25 or 30 hours in his in
his suit when he arrived
uh didn't shave often enough and intend
to his his hair
uh the way our candidates
and leaders do today but obviously he
was smart enough to have adapted and he
probably would have been extremely
persuasive do you think you would like
him well presumably he would change some
of his politics uh to update himself to
the 20th century i think he was
endlessly fascinating he was mysterious
though
i think he
he managed even with the best of his
friends and the closest of his
acquaintances
to leave a veil of mystery some
something untouchable
um you read the reminiscences of the
people who
claimed to have been closest to him and
they were probably the closest because
they were not there were no others and
there was something they couldn't touch
there was something they didn't know
there was a line that he drew they
didn't know about his childhood
they didn't know much about his family
life he didn't invite many of them home
they didn't know much about what he was
thinking he was a very very private
close-mouth person at the same time he
was a gregarious
politician and an uh you know an
enthralling speaker and a great
storyteller
it was also a wall
robert todd lincoln is buried out here
at arlington cemetery near william
howard taft but his other three kids are
buried with his wife in springfield how
come what's it
well robert
and his mother had a peculiar and
unhappy time after
after lincoln was assassinated
there was a great deal of money involved
lincoln didn't spend
much at all of his presidential salary
of 25 000 a year
it's astonishing how much he saved he
really saved 23 24 000 a year and that's
while sending
uh his son through harvard
and and it makes me very jealous because
i'm sending a daughter to harvard right
now and it's not quite the same thing i
could use the presidential salary of
abraham lincoln
so when he died and when he died
congress gave him an extra
year's salary gave his widow an extra
year salary
basically there was about 130 thousand
dollars in inheritance
and robert called in
supreme court justice david davis an old
illinois friend to manage the estate the
estate grew
and mary's spending habits became
increasingly erratic over the years
she was deeply troubled she lost a son
in the white house she lost her son in
in childhood
and then she lost the third son
tad in the 1870s
and
robert wanted control of the money he
was afraid his mother was either going
to lose it because she carried
securities and money on her person in uh
in
sacks that she had made to fit under her
skirts
and she was behaving in a
increasingly peculiar way so he
instituted commitment proceedings
and in fact she was brought to public
court and declared insane and committed
for almost a year
uh during which time he gained control
of the estate that mary was released she
had another trial proved herself saying
to the satisfaction of the court
she was treated with um
basically with marijuana which seems to
have calmed her down in in her asylum
days
and so they were really
never terribly close
and
there was a distance even between robert
and his father he didn't get to see him
much after he was elected to the
presidency he was at harvard and then at
harvard law then in the army
and
i think that robert's decision not to be
interred in the in the family tomb sort
of speaks for himself he thought of
himself as an independent person anyway
you dedicate your book uh for my
daughters is it remy or remy remy and
meg great debaters right and you talk
about the fact in your introduction that
remy is going to harvard and it didn't
matter to her i guess that when you told
her in the midst of writing this book
that robert todd lincoln had gone to
harvard too she wasn't too impressed she
wasn't terribly pressed well actually
she viewed it as an effort to denigrate
her own achievements so there were no
comparisons to be made and i stopped
making them did your daughters have any
role in your book
aside from debating constantly and
letting me hear it well they've been
they debated what were they debating
with you what what uh teenage girls
always debate about
space
power
not abraham lincoln not abraham lincoln
and not slavery and not race usually
but um no they were terrific they as i
say in the book that they're both very
good writers one is 18 and one is 14 and
i have this habit of seizing on a word
that i want to use
in in writing and then not being able to
remember it so i sort of call downstairs
what is the word that
i think it starts with an n that means
this and
whoever is downstairs yells up several
choices it's like having a living
thesaurus on another level of the house
in your family uh
was your father mother historian or they
were they interested in lincoln no
they're not the historians my father's a
businessman my mother is a housewife and
um
um i i've tried to find a genetic
explanation if there is any i i had an
uncle uh um who was a well-known
ophthalmologist named murray last
who was deeply interested in
in jewish history and judaica was a
major collector in his day but i barely
knew him he died when i was four years
old but that must be the
familial explanation for all of this how
much did a blanket have to do with
founding the republican party
well a great deal he um
the whig party which he uh
was a happy and contented member of for
the early part of his life in fact most
of his most of his political career was
spent as a whig
was just sort of dissolving with the uh
the um
growing immediacy of the slavery crisis
and um he and his uh and his the more
advanced of his whig friends some of
them became democrats decided that
what was needed was a party that was
strictly
anti-slavery expansion
and so he organized in illinois to
convert as many wigs as possible into
the new party
it's um
it's not quite comparable to the um
to the parole phenomenon which
sort of has this bottom-up
um mentality it's a grassroots
organization i think the republican
party was more leadership down old twigs
looking to organize themselves in a new
and appealing way you work for mario
cuomo he's a democrat would that make
you a democrat no it would make lincoln
oh yeah would make me a democrat would
probably make lincoln a democrat i like
to think
uh both parties claim him today i guess
they do well
i i've been present at uh speeches by
both mario cuomo and jack kemp
at which both of them lay very
convincing claim to abraham lincoln
but i tend to agree with the
with the with mario cuomo when he says
that the example that uh
puts him closest to the heart of the
democratic party is the extension of the
latter of opportunity
the the notion that everyone can improve
himself and herself
just to quickly review seven debates
in august september and october of 1858
right two years before he ran for
president exactly and won
uh
the first speaker spoke for an hour the
second for an hour and a half and the
third had a rejoinder of a half an hour
that was douglas's idea too but
the time sequence and also and also he
he made sure that he spoke first and
last at four of the seven debates was
that an advantage
oh yeah i think the person who generally
the person who spoke first and last won
the debates
won the the individual debates it just
was a you know the last word was uh was
important except maybe the last debate
where
um
douglas lost because he couldn't be
heard apparently he'd been
just devastated by the campaign
physically and he and he could barely
speak
uh and was apparently not hurt at all in
that last debate in a town square and uh
5-2
a small man big barrel chest and short
legs what would uh as a matter of fact
you've got a painting here i don't know
if you remember who actually did the
painting uh showing the difference in
their height what would he be like
if he were here
well he would have to lincoln would have
to tone up and he'd and douglas would
have to tone down i mean what kind of
person was he bombastic fierce
hard drinker smart
oh yeah yeah but a bigot
yeah
but again you know
well not to cast a glow on bigotry but
it was not
unusual
to be uh to believe in white supremacy
if you were white
in uh in 19th century america
and it you know it the lincoln himself
had to
backtrack during the entire debate
proceeding from a speech he made in
chicago
before the debate started in which he
merely said
that the declaration of independence
which decree that all men are created
equal extended not only to whites
but to blacks
that he said was the intention of the
founders of the country
well for seven debates
lincoln hemmed and hawed and explained
and revised
to get away from the notion that he had
actually spoken about racial equality
he had to do that
and he probably believed that he hadn't
spoken about racial equality
we haven't gotten to the substance of
these debates
spend a little time
uh what were the debates about
well the thing that's probably the most
remarkable
thing about the debates is that
they really were about one thing and
that's slavery
there were lots of diversions
throughout the debates you hear lincoln
and douglas attacking each other for
the most ridiculous uh
off the subject
things um
douglas attacked lincoln for his record
as a congressman during the mexican war
bringing up a you know a ten-year-old
issue saying he hadn't voted for
supplies for the soldiers
and lincoln had to defend that
lincoln accused douglas of conspiring
with the chief justice of the united
states and the president to nationalize
slavery
which was i mean lincoln knew that
wasn't true we didn't think that douglas
had had a secret meeting with
roger tony or james buchanan and uh uh
decided that we're going to bring
slavery to maine and vermont and
but
part of the debates were about
entertainment and and
and uh
getting your opponent weakening your
opponent through diversionary tactics
and there was a great deal of that all
these conspiracy theories talked about
and uh uh
lincoln
kept referring to douglas as judge
douglas and it's one of those you had to
be there things but douglas had been a
judge and lincoln had teased douglas
that he had voted as a state legislator
to expand the illinois judiciary
specifically so that he could get a
judgeship
so every time he called him judge
instead of senator he was sort of
digging the knife in a little deeper
saying you made yourself a judge
but basically the issue was slavery
expand whether or not it could be
expanded morally legally
and as a side issue again was this issue
of
equality which was a new notion
i think for the vast majority of people
in illinois a new thing for them to deal
with this possibility
that
douglas raised in an ugly way that when
frederick douglass
was riding through the streets of an
illinois city in a carriage
sitting next to white women
this
was this
the the typical view of the future
was it bearable was it endurable
was it right was it acceptable
who was frederick douglass where is he
from frederick douglass was a
born a slave and
escaped a brilliant writer who was the
uh
the leading black
figure of his day
ran a newspaper in upstate new york and
was an enormously influential
person the first african-american who
was invited to the white house
invited by abraham lincoln in the 1860s
to confer was he around any of these
debates apparently he was around
in uh freeport in the second debate town
in this carriage it's exactly where
douglas stephen that is saw frederick
and
that was the site that so infuriated him
that he referred to it there and again
and again in the debates
um
douglas was also frederick was also a
debater of sorts and he was debating he
wanted to debate stephen douglas in fact
he proposed
uh in the 1850s to have what he called
an ebony and ivory debate with stephen
douglas something i found in
the old illinois newspapers i thought
that that was a uh that ebony and ivory
was a uh
a phrase invented by paul mccartney and
michael jackson i hadn't realized that
it went back to the two douglasses
uh but douglas would know stephen
douglas would never consent to debate an
african-american so that was out of the
question let me read a little bit of
abraham lincoln from the ottawa debate
um
trying to remember whether this is the
beginning i think maybe it's
mr lincoln's reply
i will say here while i am upon this
subject i have no purpose directly or
indirectly to interfere with the
institution of slavery in the states
where it exists
i believe i have no lawful right to do
so and i have no inclination to do so i
have no disposition to introduce
political and social equality between
the white and the black races there's
more of course i want to read but what's
he saying there
well he's
he's saying what he thinks i believe
which is that
to save
the union for the future and to
permit american democracy to inspire the
rest of the world to democracy which
lincoln believed very deeply
the primary
goal was to hold the union together
and
the moral goal was to stop the spread of
slavery lincoln believed that if you
stopped allowing slavery into new states
that were forming all the time in the
west
you created sort of a situation in which
slavery would disappear in and of itself
no more slave trade
no more foreign slave trade slavery
would sort of disappear strangle itself
as he believed the founding fathers
desired from the beginning
um
on the notion of political and social
equality
i don't think lincoln was prepared for
political and social equality in 1858
i think the great emancipator that we
we think of as uh as the lincolnian
ideal
developed four or five years later in
his life he developed quickly but he
wasn't there yet in 1858 this ottawa
debate was the first one
august 21st 1858
and he goes on he says there is a
physical difference between the two
meaning the blacks and the whites
which in my judgment will probably
forever forbid their living together on
terms of respect social and political
equality and in as much as it becomes a
necessity that there must be a
superiority somewhere
i as well as judge douglas
am in favor of the race to which i
belong having the superior position
but i hold that because of all this
there is no reason at all furnished why
the negro after all is not entitled to
all that the declaration of independence
holds
he was saying what well he was saying to
all of those who could hear him i am a
middle-of-the-road republican you've
heard that i am for equality i'm really
not for equality i'm for equality of
opportunity i believe that if you earn
bread with your own hands you should eat
it with your own mouth as he joked later
in the debates if
if god meant for one class of citizens
to do all the work and another class of
citizen to get all the benefit then he
would have made workers with all hands
and no mouth and and the beneficiaries
of their labor with mouths and no hands
it was his way of saying
people should earn
the fruits of their own labors but don't
worry i'm not going to make
jurors of blacks i'm not going to make
voters of blacks i'm not going to change
the nature of politics in the state i'm
not going to empower people who could
drive you out of office or compete for
wage jobs with your children
and this is what i mean he had to do
that in order to be a viable candidate
in illinois but he wouldn't have been a
candidate in illinois if he didn't
believe that in the first place
throughout the entire seven debates uh
stephen douglas tries to position
abraham lincoln as saying one thing in
the north and one thing in the south
his creed don't travel douglas said
do you think that abe lincoln did speak
differently in jonesboro and in freeport
i think he spoke
differently in chicago and paid for it
at the rest of the debates i think he
was pretty he was pretty good in
jonesborough that was always an
astonishment to me that he was as uh as
uh true to his principles
as as he was in jonesboro of course by
then he knew that these debates were
being published in the chicago papers
picked up in the springfield papers
published in republican and democratic
papers all over the state it would have
been folly for him to be completely
different in the southern part of the
state than he was in the northern but he
was he did back back away from those
chicago sentiments of equality
throughout all of the debates no matter
where he was but to give you an idea
again you know
obviously lincoln was not for equality
in 1858 does that make him a racist well
it depends on your definition of racism
um it certainly portrays him as less of
a ra the debates portray him as less of
a racist than douglas
but
i one of the things that was eye-opening
to me again
was the beginning of his speech in
charleston
um
here he was co he was coasting he was
the hometown favorite
he had come to charleston 30 years
before as a
as a young adult he had come in with his
family in an ox cart they really liked
him there he won that area republicans
won that area that is of course there
was no direct election but republicans
did well in the fall
there were banners all over saying old
abe returns to charleston
pioneer boy comes home so he was in his
element there
and he probably could have said exactly
what he wanted to say
but what he decided to do is say
you have heard some people say that i am
for equality
of the negro
an interesting start but what is even
more interesting is the crowd reaction
laughter
they laughed at the notion
that a mainstream politician could have
ever said such a thing
which to me more
um
more strongly and more directly and more
irrefutably than any other moment of the
debates
paints a picture of what that electorate
was like the electorate was much more
racist than lincoln
and uh
lincoln did well to to
position himself as nimbly as he did and
maintain the affections of so many
voters
uh trick question i've asked some people
who can't get an easy answer in the last
couple days
at the beginning of the 13 states there
were 12
slave states and one free state what was
the free state that is a trick question
everybody i mean it's it's they
mentioned it so often in here
in the debates we will get letters on
this i want to warn you
now they mentioned they kept
uh
mr douglas kept referring to the 12
slave states in the one free state
it is a trick question terribly unfair
massachusetts
oh you don't know the answer i do not no
ah no i hope i was looking to you for
the answer well that's rational but
we'll we'll find out eventually
um
is this a book that the average person
can understand
i mean if somebody's out there listening
saying i didn't know any of that stuff i
want to should they read it what i mean
what's the advantage of reading going
through all this these seven debates
versus just listening to you talk about
um
well for one thing unless you you you
rebroadcast this for the rest of the
year that's my my efforts will be
somewhat limited but the other is that
this gives a really gives an idea of
what political debating was like before
we got uh as um
as as frightened as we seem to be now
about letting people have the full range
of their emotions and their thoughts and
speak as long as they wanted and
allowing audiences to do what they
wanted uh it paints a picture of a
political culture that's really vanished
from the united states maybe it's not a
good thing that it's vanished this idea
that people would participate in as many
numbers as they did not paid workers
not not political supporters but
ordinary people who came in ox carts and
ferries and trains horseback or walked
came in such numbers that towns looked
like dust bowls there was dust rising in
shrouding towns from the numbers of
people
and it paints a picture of
political involvement and excitement
about government that we don't have
anymore and that we've lost
and uh you know i'd like to you refer at
one point that everybody voted yeah it
was like 90 turnout in 1860 when lincoln
ran for the presidency
it was huge 90 turnout of white males oh
yes absolutely 90 of eligible voters
i don't think white males are doing so
well in turnout these days so
there's been a drop off of interest
senator douglas
or as mr lincoln referred to him judge
douglas constantly referred to black
republicans what what did he mean by
that he meant that the party that
lincoln had founded was cast
uh he meant it in the most pejorative
way possible was cast as an abolition
party they were all pro-black they were
practically black themselves nothing
worse could be said about a politician
by another politician
but when the democratic papers
did the transcripts of douglas the ones
that i don't use
they took out black and they just made
it republican whenever douglas said
[ __ ] the democratic papers changed it
to negro that's why i went back to the
opposition transcripts because they
didn't have those embellishments and
those edits and that's softening
uh dred scott comes up all the time
chief justice tawny and the dredge scott
decision who was dred scott dred scott
which was uh by the way became an issue
yesterday in the ginsburg
confirmation hearings everyone agreed
that dred scott was a bad thing which i
thought was amusing in the hearings
obviously it was a bad thing dred scott
was a slave
who in the 1850s or even earlier had
been taken by his master into free
territory
and then returned to slave territory
and in a test case uh
scott's um
has sued
um for his freedom saying that once he
was in a free territory he was a free
man
and the supreme court under
roger tawny slaveholding marylander
been there since the age of jackson
um declared that slaves were slaves no
matter where they were
that slaves were property that they
weren't human that they were perpetually
ineligible for citizenship
and therefore in a way
slavery could be nationalized
so it was a
a watershed that um that probably did
more than any other um single event
to divide the country and bring it to
the brink of disunion
when did again when did you first start
working on this particular book in in 90
early 92
and you finished it
i guess early 91 excuse me and i
finished it in
mid 92
and
in order to do this did you have to go
to illinois
i went to illinois to find out if i
could get hold of
those
newspapers that had never been consulted
before the democratic version of lincoln
the republican version of douglas so i
had to dig up the old chicago times
which is not in great condition and
where i couldn't find the chicago times
i had to go to the springfield papers so
yeah there was some travel there and to
get those papers and i wanted to look at
some of the debate towns again
what they look like today
they look
still looked small but they're obviously
bigger but some of them have markers on
the
spots where lincoln spoke knox college
in galesburg is
is still there and
they had they moved the platform that
day because it was so windy
they moved it to the side of the college
to protect the speakers from the wind
and it created my favorite the debate
quote of the debates lincoln had to go
up through the building and out the
window to get on the platform and he
said well at last i've gone through
college
is there anything special about these
two pictures on the cover here uh
well both were taken in around 1858
that's the best i wanted the pictures to
represent them as they looked although
lincoln looks rather well dressed
for in that picture on the left and
although it's always been identified as
1858 i have my suspicions i think it
might in fact now that the book is out
it might be an 1860 presidential
campaign picture he looked pretty seedy
during most of the debates
have the debates ever been reenacted
that you know well they're reenacted all
the time but they're not
in fact i just came back from chicago
well not just came back about a month
ago
i spoke before the stephen a douglas
association in chicago which
exists and thrives there
among his old neighbors and their
descendants they go to his tomb every
year and
they have a speaker at an annual dinner
where's he burying in chicago in a park
in chicago and
there were these two guys from central
illinois i wish i remember their names
because they were terrific a tall
science teacher and a short insurance
salesman
and they were absolutely terrific the
the the uh the lincoln character is
about six foot seven so he really gives
an impression about of what lincoln
might look like to today's people who
are taller than they were in lincoln's
day
they were just wonderful but they can't
dig they can't do three-hour debates
because no one would sit through it
let alone stand through it as they did
then so they do a half-hour program and
you can hear the rustling in the seats
you've been we've been spoiled by what
we expected debates
what's next for you
um dear mr lincoln which is a collection
of the letters to lincoln um coming out
in the fall and unfortunately because of
my brilliant marketing acumen which is
what i supposedly do for a living
another book in the fall called mine
eyes have seen the glory
the civil war in art
um which is also going to be brought out
in the fall and is co-authored with my
long-time and frequent collaborator
mark e neely jr
we've got just a short time i shouldn't
do this to you what's the metropolitan
museum of art
and what's your job there i'm the chief
communications officer of the greatest
museum art museum in the world certainly
the greatest in the united states and it
has a complete encyclopedia of the great
creativity of men and women from
civilizations uh
from the birth of uh creativity
right up to baseball cards which we just
opened
at the mat the jefferson burdick
collection of baseball cards so we run
the gamut and we have things for
everyone
here's what this book looks like it's
called the lincoln douglas debates
harold holzer was the man that put this
together and it's the first complete
unexplorated text thank you very much
for joining us thank you
join us next week on booknotes when our
guest will be peter mcdonald who was an
officer in the british army for over 30
years
and the author of the recent biography
zap
the victor in vietnam
general vo nuenzap commander of the
vietnamese army during the indochina and
vietnam wars currently lives in hanoi
and will celebrate his 82nd birthday on
august 28th
that's book notes next sunday night at 8
and 11 p.m eastern time
coming next on c-span a look at politics
in great britain
so
[Music]
welcome to this week's look at politics
in the united kingdom
at the end of july the british
parliament